turn your great idea into a reality with
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project
whether you're showcasing your work or
selling products of any kind they have
beautiful templates and the ability to
customize just about anything you can
easily make a beautiful website all by
yourself but you know if you do get
stuck they have 24/7 award-winning
customer support that is there to help
you out so go to Squarespace comm slash
grace for a free trial and when you are
ready to launch use the offer code grace
grac e to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain welcome
to a brand new episode of not too deep
this is very exciting guys because we
have revamped our format a little bit
and given you guys what you've been
asking for which is a video version of
each episode of the podcast we're
starting right here right now if you're
only listening to this you can find the
video version on my youtube channel
youtube.com slash grace Helbig and the
cool thing about this new format is that
we're spending some more time with the
guests we're really kind of diving in
maybe in a little deep maybe stay on the
surface you'll have to you know tune in
to find out and as always check fairy
the lifeblood of this podcast is still
here with us he's behind the scenes
hijack very see ya he's not being held
like a kidnapped person right now he is
here on his own accord and we're very
excited to bring to you this brand new
refreshed version today our first guest
is Candace King she's an absolutely
lovely
artist actress actor
philanthropist mom you'll hear all about
it she's insanely wonderful it shows as
a brand new podcast called directionally
challenged but should go check out and
let's just jump right in
I don't want to waste your time maybe
that's the new log line for the podcast
hooray hey guys were here with canvas
King this is so exciting I said that I
didn't want to talk too much beforehand
cuz I have so much that I want to ask
you about just like your life in general
I did the Google o made up a lot your
life makes me tired because you've done
so much stuff it's nuts I feel like you
wear 10,000 different hats
that's funny cuz when I think about you
I'm like I really need to step up my
game a god bless ya god bless know this
so you're one year okay how do you even
rank what you describe your profession
as like do you say actress first you say
creative singer mom like where do you
rank all of that I say actor okay yeah
and then everyone always goes like you
mean actress I'm like sure whatever yeah
is that the taboo thing I don't it
doesn't bother me
maybe I just actors a shorter word to
write you know I know for sure and then
I think it's almost weirdly like an
afterthought that you're a mom which is
a completely full-time job and like I
have a dog and that's too much you need
a handle like and you came in here just
like effortlessly refreshed and was like
I had to deal with my kid I'm like I
don't even I can't wrap my brain around
that yeah I still can't wrap my brain
around it like I'm already like okay I'm
picking up our 13 year old because she
started school this week so she's gonna
be like at the after school and then our
almost 16 year old has volleyball today
so she's taking care of she starts
driving soon and then our two and a half
year old like was supposed to be home
but because she's was sick yesterday so
she's at like a quick daycare so okay
the teenagers obviously are interested
in the world in which you work on a
daily basis or are they not not really a
kind of you know I think there
dad my husband is a musician right so
they grew up to the two coolest parents
that I could have like literally prayed
for every night that I'd wake up my
parents would be like successful and
creative types I mean we like to think
we like to be like yeah but we're cool
and we're like hip and we're young and
we offer all these like cool hip ideas
uh-huh
and they're usually like okay whatever
guys over it yeah okay
my question for you because I still like
to learn this from like teens and tweens
is how do you handle their relationship
with social media it's such a tricky one
yeah that one's really hard on one hand
it's encouraging of you know like our 13
year old Ava she's she watches all the
shows on YouTube and she loves slime and
so she is like a fig it's a big moment
who's not really had to cut her off we
were running out of laundry detergent so
often that I was like I'm dockage like
no more like this is my laundry
detergent and you have to use your
allowance money to buy your own laundry
detergent now you know some parents deal
with like drug issues with their kids
and you're dealing with slime we didn't
do it yeah it was really fun for the
holidays we had a bunch of friends over
and we had a bunch of cocktails and wine
and so we were like Ava you need to do a
slime demonstration also you wanted for
Christmas we're so we're gallons of glue
so we had like 4 gallons of glue under
the Christmas tree
that's a Merry Christmas is very very
millennial very 2018 very very much yeah
okay you met this is tell me if this
internet fact is true you met your
husband at the Super Bowl yes okay talk
me through this how did this happen well
I'm sure you've told this story a
million oh I actually haven't told it
that often in this kind of a setting
okay we so Nina Dobrev worked on the
Vampire Diaries she had the opportunity
to go to the Super Bowl I was kind of
going through a rough patch and she was
like come with me and I was like that's
the best solution for any girl having a
hard time as go to the Super Co to the
Super Bowl
hey and she's like all we have to do is
play in this little like celebrity flag
football game I was like I love that I
was on a winning powderpuff team junior
high wait what is this caveat that you
have to go to the Super Bowl but to get
there you have to play in a power
powderpuff game yes which I love that
I'm like great there's a game there's a
mission and then we get to celebrate by
going to the Super Bowl okay min okay
what I did not know though was that this
was a Direct TV 3d televised event what
so we showed up and you get like a
little sheet of like the schedule and so
it's like warm-up time and I'm like
great we're gonna and we play with a
bunch of other you know celebrities and
and then a bunch of professional
football players so I'm like this is
awesome like we're gonna be able to
practice and throw the ball around work
some plays cut to the warm-up here it is
just a red carpet and I have no makeup
on by the way I have like pigtails no
MACO you're genuinely gonna go play
again yes and I was like we're just
gonna play this game in a field to know
other people in the business we're
having literally like yeah our work
field day today there won't be any
cameras involved none and no it was a
red carpet and then I realized I was
like okay everyone was like in the back
room all the girls are like doing their
makeup and it's like Maria Menounos
who's beautiful and Joey Sparks is like
lacing up or tennis shoes and like Anita
knows all these people I'm like the
worst person in this industry ever like
I don't go to parties I'm the person who
wants to sit in the corner and just be
like look at everyone like I still think
I'm in real food here yeah exactly I go
for the open bar in the free food every
single day yeah my spirit animal is just
an open bar yeah yeah done and so we get
out there and Nina's on the other team
and so now you weren't even on the same
you know not even on the same team
and so I've got like Kate Upton on our
team doll oh it could not be nicer but
everyone wants to see Kate Upton hike
the ball
oh just touch a football that's touch
the football oh no no one wants to see
like me with my pigtails and like no
makeup on like out there working it with
my flat I'm a deity by osmosis listening
to this yeah this is my nightmare so
and then everyone's all cool and like I
even went up to this guy backstage who
I'd like the same shirt color as me and
I was like hey we're on the same team
and he was like yeah okay
and that was my future husband by the
way so no one would talk to me and and
no one would throw a ball around because
everyone knows each other because
they're all cool celebrities and like
all the football players know each other
and the only other person standing by
themselves was Joe Montana do you mind
like throwing the ball around with me
and he was like yes Joe Montana oh yeah
and he did he was the only one that
would warm up with me throwing the ball
around and that got my future husband's
attention so our first picture together
is me and Joe Montana laughing and
talking and my husband's just in the
background like waiting with this like
baby face being like hey I'll be cool
like yeah I want to be introduced oh my
god my husband and I were on the same
team he's a musician like he's very he's
one of those annoying people that is
just good at everything like oh yeah you
know musician on tour he plays pool he
plays darts he carry inspiring and also
just like a pain in the ass yeah you're
like okay we get it
yeah football is not his strong suit so
we were kind of benched most of the game
so it was my husband me and Neil Patrick
Harris who stood on the sidelines for
most of the game this is the craziest
meet-cute story of all time and so we
ended up talking and we really hit it
off the new I had been going through a
rough time and I laughed for the first
time in a long time and I just really
liked him yeah and then his band the
fray was performing like the end of the
game so I watched him play a few songs
and I was like but he didn't really like
look at me and I was like oh whatever so
I like I don't want to be a groupie or
weird yeah like it's just weird it just
felt nice to like that was nice I talked
to a really nice
guy and he made me laugh and it feels
good just you know throwing the pigskin
around with Joe Montana so I get back to
like the changing room and Mina was like
did you give him your number and I was
like no I'm not gonna give him my number
I don't even know him too so she wrote
down my number passed it to the cleaning
woman in our room who gave it to the
cleaning woman in the guy's room who
then gave it to their tour manager and
my husband was the only single one of
the whole band oh my like that was it
that's a dangerous pass off like a lot
of different outlets before it got
somehow it got to him and then we
started texting we bet we never saw each
other the rest of the weekend we bet on
the game I lost and so I owed him a
dozen hotdogs so but yeah so I text him
being like hey I gotta keep my end of
the bet where can I send the hotdogs and
after that for like the next three
months we talked until he finally
convinced me to go on a first date with
him oh my god that is so sweet and
that's how we know so do you guys know
because that's kind of your origin story
when the Superbowl happens every year is
that a special moment for you guys is a
weird thing to celebrate do you
celebrate it we do celebrate it and my
husband loves football like it's on
every Sunday he's a huge Broncos fan cuz
he's from Denver so it's a big deal we
actually went to the New Orleans Super
Bowl the next year in and then he played
the Frey played a party for the big
Broncos we're not supposed to mention it
but the Broncos Seattle Seahawks game
okay
the Broncos basically will blur it out
it was bad we had like middle 50-yard
line tickets like second row and it was
for anyone that watched the game
basically like the Broncos from the
minute one it was bad you can win and we
bought we stood in line for like an hour
and bought like hundreds and hundreds of
dollars worth of merch that all have
this so we haven't been back to the
Super Bowl since but maybe one day
there's always time for new memories
always time for new memories so yes we
did meet up the Super Bowl that is an
incredibly sweet story and you guys have
been married for how many years now
three going on four in October
okay that's nuts how was the the wedding
itself great we got married in New
Orleans cuz we we actually just moved in
together a year ago wait so you were
married and not living together yes so
our running joke is first we met then we
got married then we had a baby and now
we're moving in together
these are all important life events and
sometimes they don't happen happening
like chronologically for some girls yeah
you got there eventually he collected
them all okay when Julie
so okay explain this roller coaster then
well because he was a musician always on
the road doing you know I we have her
older girls I have two stepdaughters and
so they were all in Denver our main
house was in Denver
but I was filming the Vampire Diaries in
Atlanta okay and we filmed nine months
out of the year yeah that was that's and
I want to get into it like that whole
world because that's obviously like an
insane part of your life but managing a
relationship at the same time with kids
involved it seems nuts to me it was and
then now looking back it just kind of
worked because we were both around so
many people that had lived the same life
yeah like it's complimentary then yeah
if we were just at a dinner party with
friends that all lived in the same city
they would be like that's crazy but you
know when I was on set all of the people
I worked with are either in long
distance relationships or they lived in
the same city but because of our crazy
work hours you never see each other
anyway yeah you know if you're shooting
nights and someone else is shooting days
and you just so it kind of worked her we
had these little patches of time of like
weeks at a time or you just really kind
of connect with each other yeah and it
was a I thought it was great now looking
back I'm like I could plan when to shave
my legs weird TV and like my weird
dinners like don't you like I miss just
being able to make a weird [ __ ]
dinner of just like oh yeah just eating
the tops of pizza and not having anyone
judge you for it yeah is it a wonderful
liberating experience as a woman I'm
like a tip person so like three
different kinds of like a pretzel chip a
pita chip and then I go thousand I'm
very into dip dinners as a like potluck
type of scenario for friends to gather
around just bring dips and
things to dip in and then see what
happened make a meal yeah exactly but
that okay so the chaos of it kind of
really worked for you guys it did to
where when we moved to Los Angeles a
year ago and everything kind of slowed
down like he's man sized in some
traditional sense
yeah bands not touring right now I'm not
on a show or any working any like crazy
production hours here so we're both I've
always wanted to just be home so we
could be together be with the kids and
then we got there and we were like oh my
gosh oh no my move so slow that must be
such a different adjustment to kind of
like this is what people deal with
regularly this sort of like timeline and
schedule and like the normalcy of like
waking up in the same bed in the same
town in the same time zone so to adjust
to something that's so good like
traditionally normal must feel strange
we also always plant whenever we were
together we were inseparable
because we knew we'd only have a week
together or like a long weekend so it
took us a minute to be able to go okay
I'm going to the gym alone without you
is that ok and he's like I'm going
golfing without you okay
we'll see you after that well yeah we'll
eventually see each other and this is
okay and we live here together now and
this one singular house so weird no
that's very sweet though okay so let's
talk a little bit about Vampire Diaries
which obviously is like a huge portion
of your life yeah and it is a very
intense portion of your life so what
were you doing right before you got the
call to be on Vampire Diaries I was
writing a fake resume to try to get a
waitressing job perfect absolutely
you're writing a fake resume to get a
waitressing dress cuz I've never been a
waitress and it's so competitive out
here I become a waitress it is like a
going on an audition it is yeah and I'd
I'd been a personal assistant and then I
for a while I worked with a like
for-profit nonprofit where I was one of
those people that stood out in front of
grocery stores to like raise money for
an organization people that
I pretend I'm deaf in front of ya yeah I
was okay it's okay now I have a toddler
I can be like she'll cry if you talk to
us she'll scream like yeah but I have
like yeah and then I was like a backup
singer for a while oh yeah you were on
tour with Miley Cyrus yes many many
moons ago so a light part of your resume
a little spice in there okay quickly how
long was the tour that you were on with
Miley Cyrus a little over a year a
little over a year okay and you've
released her own music since then mm
kind of it was very weird basically I
had been on a label I got signed when I
was I just turned 17 Wow and so I got my
parents allowed me to stay out here my
mom moved out here with me I made a
record and it just eventually got
shelves and I got dropped and then what
a fun feeling at 17 yeah you know really
boost the confidence in your formative
years and and then some production
company I'd worked with said that they
could release it in Japan okay so the
only places it's really been released is
Japan and and then it's on iTunes as I
say people like look for it on Spotify
or anywhere online Beverly I've never
looked for it I'm tasking the audience
you know one mission please go find all
this music I mean it's huge in Japan it
was huge yeah I just got this like stack
of magazines in a box one day where is
just my face on all these Japanese
magazine are you serious yes it was the
weirdest thing and I've never been to
Japan and I never did anything what why
how I have no idea but it happened I
feel like I don't know it feels like
such a joke you're like hold onto these
forever forever forever I kind of want
to like have an office now I feel very
sophisticated of it so I kind of want to
like put it in oh I'm gonna get an oil
painting for you should be remembered
yeah that's insane okay so you did that
which sounds tough but then you got back
into kind of like the hustling world of
Los Angeles
yes scenario did you live in Los Angeles
from 17 on yeah so I lived here for six
years until I got Vampire Diaries and
that's when I moved and that's when life
changed infinitely life changed
infinitely and it also didn't in a lot
of ways okay in the ways that it changed
were that I wasn't within a year I
wasn't stressed about money anymore I'm
sure I lived with I had family in
Atlanta so I got to live with my and the
entire series was shot in Atlanta I
didn't know that we did the pilot in
Vancouver okay but for eight years yeah
we all had Georgia licenses like I mean
we were there nine months out of the
year that's great I mean and that's so
interesting because you would assume
that with with such a successful series
that you guys all live and breathe in
Los Angeles but in fact you spent most
of your time in Georgia most of our time
was in Georgia and then a lot of the
cast would fly back to LA a lot or spent
hiatus in LA sure but I just loved it
Lana and this was before the only shows
that we're really filming there in the
beginning we're walking dead and then
drop dead diva I think it was what a
spectrum lifetime it I mean there's no
it was not really a film TV industry yet
there so for us we were all in our early
20s we got to just go out and like stay
up way too late just way too much have
way too much fun and it was never an
issue like I've heard just even from you
know friends or acquaintances from like
Glee or Gossip Girl you know that if
you're living in LA or you're living in
New York it's like okay we're all done
by guys like yeah we'll have red carpets
or people are going to the hottest
nightclub buat season issue
for us it was we would rap on a Friday
night at 3:00 in the morning and then
we'd all take over our favorite wine bar
till the Sun came up and not just as a
cast I mean the entire crew that's so
nice we like most of my closest like
girlfriends are either significant
others of crew members I worked with or
or they were part of the crew that I
got to know over the years yeah so I
mean we were just really close as a
production it was great it must feel
very family-oriented when you can't be
close to your family yes we were a
family like we an especially that's why
I like towards the end when I was
pregnant and my husband couldn't be
there all the time I still felt like I
was around family all the time yeah yeah
yeah and we have this shorthand and you
know we could all melt down in front of
each other and it's not weird or crazy
and so you know you're safe when you can
be a complete struggle monster in front
of people and then still look them in
the eyes the next day yes we can all
look each other than on a Monday in the
eyes after a Friday night or if we all
had a meltdown in the middle of the
workday yeah oh that's so great okay
we're gonna lose some of the sincerity
of the podcast in a second after we take
this quick break and come back and ask
you some of the more not too deep
related questions we'll be right back
with Candace King I'm not too deep you
know what I always say grace that you're
thankful that Squarespace sponsored this
episode of not too deep oh it's funny
that you say that what I was actually
going to say is what I always say is
that you can turn your dream into a
reality with who with Squarespace whoa
we see that coming I love these guys
they make making a website so easy like
easier than ever whether you're looking
to start a new business showcase your
work publish content
sell products and more Squarespace I'm
telling you it's the tool for you it
really makes it something that seems
completely out of reach for a regular
person completely available they have
beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks you can easily make a beautiful
website all by yourself and they've got
powerful ecommerce functionality to let
you sell anything online and analytics
to help you grow your site in real time
and this is something that I think
people overlook but they have you
covered everything is optimized for
mobile right out of the box there's
nothing to patch or upgrade ever as if
we even knew what those things meant I
know what they are and I don't have to
do it even though I have made my own
Squarespace sites
well I'm just saying I'm not the most
technically proficient person but it's
nice to know that you know even if you
need help they've got 24/7 award-winning
customer support and they also make
buying domains really simple super
simple they empower millions of people
from Jack fairies to designers to
lawyers artists gamers restaurants gyms
they help people turn great ideas into
something real and so guys we've said
this before and we will say it again
because they're our friends and they
make a great product go check it out by
going to squarespace.com slash grace for
your free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code grace grac e
to save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain that is
squarespace.com slash grace offer code
grace support for today's show comes
from nutria ful nutria fall is a new
safe and effective strategy to help you
take control of your hair health it's
made with 100% drug-free nutraceutical
ingredients clinically shown to improve
thinning hair it's recommended by over
850 top physicians and some of the top
salons in the country there are numerous
causes of hair loss whether it be
menopause postpartum or issues with
sleep nutria ful can help
ashwagandha found a nutria fall I'm very
proud of myself for pronouncing that
that sounded great thank you
basically it's a stress a pigeon that
can help protect the hair from the
negative effects of cortisol it reduces
the body's response to stress helping
with depression and anxiety as well as
hair health nutria Falls formula
nourishes the hair from within and since
it's made with medical grade botanical
ingredients there are no bad side
effects or compromises to overall
wellness and it's available in two
distinct formulas one for men one for
women to suit your specific metabolic
needs and I will say they sent me the
women's formula and I've been taking it
and my hair guess what is good feeling
healthy feeling healthy and I get my
hair done a lot on set when we shoot
different projects and so it's always
you know embarrassing if you're not
showing up ready to ready to go and so
it's been nice to feel like also as a
girl that had tape and extensions for
many years of her life and needs some
hair repair it's really been a true true
help to help grow the strength and
you know just overall kind of like my
hair just feels empowered I mean it's
important yeah it feels very trendy that
you know the empowerment of women
especially in their hair
so the neutrophils formula for women is
specifically developed with women's
lifestyles and life cycles in mind so
unlike men whose primary hair health
concern is genetics for women stress
plays a huge role in their hair thinning
it definitely does for me the daily
demands of work or life balance juggling
we all do that as best as we can
it created stress hormones in our bodies
that are not our hair follicles best
friends turns out same with life cycles
our body's changed from preventative to
postpartum to postmenopausal women have
unique needs when it comes to hair
health and neutrophil has a unique
formula just for women so go to
neutrophil calm to learn more and you
can get your first month supply with
subscription for the only ten bucks by
visiting neutrophil com that's nu tra
fol calm and using the promo code grace
during checkout again that's nu T ra f o
el com offer KO grace to get your first
month supply for $10 with subscription
okay we're gonna get in just weird
questions I always have especially with
such a kind of hyper popular franchise
like being on the Vampire Diaries
you must have crazy stories or bizarre
stories of people coming up to you in
public or seeing you on a plane or
things like that like do you have any
standout moments of those moments
standout moments you're one I had a
weird moment where I was getting I got a
massage okay and then afterwards I sat
up but you know like a blanket on and I
just said thank you that was great and
then she recognized me and started
crying no like naked under a sheet like
in a room with her crying there's an
adult woman adult woman
and I didn't know how to be like cool
yes I'm glad you liked the show I'm like
what you touch my naked body yes for an
hour yeah so that one's pretty weird
everyone's pretty nice for the most part
I'm obviously a genuinely the general
fanbase I'm sure I'm assuming it's like
young sweet girls young sweet girls I
always say it's a lot of pushy parents
sometime oh really
yeah that's you know even when you know
even as we talked like the Miley tour
that I went on I remember even watching
that and like being in the hotel and it
was all these crazy parents always being
like we're gonna go find her hotel room
honey I'm getting you a picture with
Miley it just crazy parents and
logistically like on paper the things
that they're saying out loud are
unfortunate and don't make sense and you
just want to tell the kids like you've
got this like you don't need them you
can just come up and talk to me but yeah
generally everyone's really nice I think
the boys probably get more of the
aggressive sure you know moves of like a
hat pulling or a hey bite me no one
really wants me to bite them the only
the best yeah you know the only time I
kind of say no is when I'm with family
or yeah they're nice day yeah I guess
that's you know and we got a lot of
Twitter questions that we'll get into in
a little bit and everyone seems very
respectful and very like understanding
that the fan base is like ravenous in so
many ways but also like identifies that
you guys are people yeah yeah has your
family or significant other had any
experiences by default yeah my the fan
art is real good so a lot of like the
tag like you get tagged and Instagram on
up a lot of pictures and I remember the
first year my husband and I were dating
he was like very public or did you try
to keep it kind of offline we kept it
offline he also because we were dating
and he's got kids so that's played a big
factor and it wasn't necessarily like we
don't want the public to know he's being
respectful it was like I wanted before I
even met the kids I didn't want them to
we were just trying to be respectful for
a potential blended family sure and but
I just remember him being like I just
didn't realize that you and Joseph
Morgan did so many intimate photos bring
up like I'm insecure when you go to a
bar with your friends this is a very
specific thing
tagged in these pictures with like just
my face and Joseph Morgan who play the
character called Klaus and that's a
really big fandom they call you guys
we're alive
yeah like ship and so they'd put us like
in a bathtub or like holding each other
with his sheets and he was like oh my
god like I just didn't realize and I was
like these are fake
and then when we got married they like
put Joseph's space where his was and a
lot of our wedding photos understand all
the mindset of someone being like a
hangin open Photoshop right now watch
this this little rock their marriage
it's impressive and part of me is just
like can you just fix my rosacea I'm
like help a girl out like tone up my
biceps you know in the waist like give
me a little somethin make it you know
that's so funny yeah I want a funny
conversation to have as a couple
really yeah the only and then the other
one was it was just weird when I was
pregnant because they didn't release the
pregnancy storyline until later so I was
still doing like make out and love
scenes oh my god I had like a proper
belly oh no it was weird like that's
real acting though to be very fair I
know some serious acting kudos to you
like poor Paul he played Stephan and so
I just was so awkward because he'd have
to like rip my like it just wasn't so
bad and if like you could you could feel
like my belly underneath it's weird it
was very weird that's so nuts that was
weird so fun to navigate Hollywood yeah
what's the worst piece of advice
anyone's ever given you oh man I take
these questions so seriously oh you know
what for all the stepmoms out there
that automatically I just got a lot of
people saying that like my the its I'm
just gonna have a hard time and the kids
are gonna hate me and it's all gonna be
bad all the time and any a lot of
literature I read about yeah being a
stepparent that was like that and even
being just a like a mother to our child
together yeah you know that that I have
that you gotta go tour preschools the
second that you're pregnant you know
what yeah I didn't do that I found a
preschool a week before she got in it
you know what and it's great and and
it's not always easy like bringing a
blended family together but I'm really
proud to say that you know their parents
have raised these incredible girls that
welcomed me and you know with open heart
so that I would say to like blended
families just don't listen to all the
noise I mean it's your family and it's
your journey and it's everyone's
independent journey within that I think
that's super significant I think there's
just the mindset of staying open-minded
to something instead of assuming
preemptively things are gonna go bad or
I'm not enough or I'm not doing
something correctly causes more issues
that aren't necessary yeah I think it's
a lot a lot of the bad advice has been
parenting based fun yeah which is a
world I get anxiety about just the idea
of thinking about it to flip the switch
a little bit what is your guilty like
pleasure in terms of like TV media or
like an Instagram account that you
follow something that you're like I hate
that this is such trash but I love it so
much I don't say that I hate it because
I really I feel like I'm a part of these
families lives and I watch these
children grow up for the last what is it
now eight years who is what is this all
the teen moms oh my boyfriend is weirdly
obsessed with Teen Mom og everything my
dream was always like what are you
watching I'm like Catelynn and Tyler
going through a hard time right now okay
they're just trying to get their house
and their clothing line off like the
ground and they're doing a great job
Chelsea after all these years I'm so
team Chelsea it's pretty nuts I'm I love
that you love that I love all the team
like Teen Mom 2 Teen Mom og like I'm a
time they have oh I don't want them to
do any more and I'm really stressed out
that they're bringing in new people like
I'm like really stressed out that
Bristol Palin's gonna do it because I
wait Bristol Palin is doing it yeah I
saw rumors that she might be doing it
but she's she's not a teen I know I
don't I know I don't know it's really
stressful I just want to focus on these
moms that I've followed from day one
that's incredibly hard and they still
follow the original like Farrah
Abraham's I feel like is still
everywhere yeah she's really she's a lot
yeah I think for anyone that watches it
she's kind of made her own bed just on
an attitude perspective and just how
she's even treated I've just had a hard
time watching how she's treated her
family and then also how her family is
then not her dad but like how the
family's really responded to fame but
also at the same time I've never been
that age and suddenly Ben was insanely
famous person and yeah that's how I
don't know if I'd handle it exactly like
her but you know I don't know I have so
much empathy and sympathy and I just
really watched them from day one and if
you had any on your podcast yet no no oh
my god I was like dream number one guest
if you could have any of them if you
like hokey mugs like them all well watch
Vanderpump rules and I know you had
Stassi on I'm very jealous I would that
that was me literally desperately trying
to keep my [ __ ] together the entire
episode and occasionally Stassi shoutout
to you as a wonderful person she'll like
my instagrams every now and then and I
it makes me feel so oddly accomplished
yeah in my life I don't know why but
yeah I'm obsessed with that forget I
love Vanderpump rules I'm I try to
convince everyone who hasn't seen it
perform like no but you have to watch it
from the beginning like a real soap
opera it really is and have you gone to
Tom Tom the new restaurant I've ever
even been to pump like I just moved here
I've not been to any of that good
you let me know Lisa when the kids are
settled one night we'll go to Palm and
then we'll do a full like bar tour and
go to TomTom and hit all the spots we
don't need to go to Villa Blanca it's
more like a daytime lunch situation yeah
oh my gosh I would love that yeah okay
so who of that franchise would you like
completely lose your [ __ ] over I I think
I'd have to say I just have to say
Stassi so I knew I started watching the
show because anyway so I mean we don't
have to give reasons why we watch these
shows I think I recognized someone on
the show who who I'd basically I was
like it's not a big deal I usually
basically when I was 18 I had a
boyfriend I wasn't very nice to him it
was and he was on the show he was not on
the show okay so I didn't start Vampire
Diaries till I was 22
okay so when I was 18 I had like one of
my first boyfriends I was not a good
girlfriend we're all favorite teen
regardless and so she there was a girl
who she he started dating afterward and
you know it was just one of those I was
like oh my gosh that was that girl that
I like and she's on the show and she's
on the show so then I watched it and
then I was like this is so crazy and
then I was in it and then I got sucked
in I mean you literally did the
equivalent of when we go and check our
exes instagrams and then we find who
they're dating and then we deep dive
into their Instagram unfortunately you
just happened to be on a reality show
that you got to absorb I know and it was
like almost a decade later it was so
weird it was great and then I was like
what is this show yeah I have all the
same questions that you have like how
does this group of friends hang out all
the time like I'm so stressed out it's
nuts plus I I do the kind of new gross
thing that I don't enjoy that I do this
but I deep dive into their instagrams to
see if they are genuinely friends you
know when the seasons not shooting and
then they are yeah and that's what makes
it more interesting to watch that I'm
like this feels pretty real then and now
they're all hanging out on Lala's jet oh
god I can't I mean talk about the music
Oh talk about really groundbreaking
musician and Lella Ken it's really great
if you want to come on the podcast
lalala I would love to have you as a
guest can I cater it just to be can I do
crafty just have you ever had a complete
kind of retro actively embarrassing
fangirl moment with someone all the time
when am I not putting my foot in my
mouth I do not handle like celebrity
sightings very well okay like I remember
even just like maybe a few years ago my
husband it was like Kenneth serious Lena
Dunham you should go say hi like oh dang
you're such a big fan and you know just
be like hey girl you're cool yeah and I
was like don't look at her say her name
out loud I'm just gonna walk around this
store quietly and acknowledge that she's
in my presence and that is it we are not
talking about it like you're like how do
humans human how did you walk when they
don't want to be noticed for like being
uncomfortable and yeah yeah no it has
never gone well when I try to say hi to
anyone even like Jenny Mullin I don't do
yeah yeah oh I love her she's so funny
love her she's so funny
we have the same and I heard her
relationship were like real true goals
of like a relationship I know yeah I
love it and I love the way she just puts
herself out there and I just absolutely
adore her and we have the same hair and
makeup person we've worked with a bunch
and so I saw her at a party and he was
like oh my gosh you have to go say hi so
it just was like hey girl
I know Brett you know Brett we both we
both know Brett so like you're awesome
and like and we I know Brett okay
because you know Brett who does eat us
hair and makeup and you're just really
awesome and she I think okay you feel
comfortable because you like my
initiator to this conversation I'd got
on lock salep and then any follow-up
after that I'm floundering and fully
floundered
I just keep repeating that we know the
same people expecting a conversation to
develop out of that yeah well that's I
mean those I feel like are decent enough
people to fangirl in front of I feel
like they would find the comedy and that
rather than the uncomfortability in that
I need to work on it though like I had
an audition where Genji Cohen was in the
oh my god and I couldn't not look at her
like I literally it was so bad it was
one of the worst auditions I'd had in
such a long time and I I was so hot and
read like I think I might be I get I
know that's really bad things and I was
so blushed that I took my jacket off in
between scenes and they're like costume
change
like toss this over here I'm cool get
ready yeah I know that is so funny no
I'm the same way where I forget to
function properly and it doesn't get
executed well my idea of what
functioning properly it looks like or
sounds like and yeah it's it's never a
good scenario at all whatsoever
what's your person that you've ooh um I
I'm pretty one I'm pretty terrible at
like recognizing people like I'll look
at someone and go I think that's a
famous person but I don't know why I did
see Paul Rudd in the airport one time
picking up his luggage and he just looks
completely like Paul Rudd
yeah [ __ ] spoiler Paul Rudd looks like
Paul no I was just picking up his
luggage at the luggage carousel with all
the plebeians and he just was so
unassuming and clearly was like trying
not to make eye contact with them yeah
try not to bring any attention to
himself and he just seemed so cool and
so calm that I was just like I this is
obviously not a moment for me to have
what Paul read but he looks so
infinitely cooler than I could ever be
in my life and that was a moment that I
was like I think I'm nervous
I think I'm very nervous to be in the
same space I don't want to do anything
stupid in front of this person yeah I
think that's like probably the Oh Abby
Lee Miller from Dance Moms yeah she was
one that was just like I'm wearing a
Tasmanian Devil shirt and that's exactly
how she was and exactly how I expected
her to be in person and that was a real
sweet wonderful crazy moment to meet her
yeah she was nuts but she's also one of
those people that's like you know she'll
never remember anything you do in front
of her because she's just kind of in her
own chaos pray constantly so she feels
like a safe person to fangirl in front
of because she kind of expects everyone
to think she's awesome all the time too
which I
you probably think she's a Looney tune
but a wonderful one at that so yeah I
think those are probably my biggest big
spectrum I'm Paul Rudd and Abby Lee
Miller but a good one that Kayla and I
actually became really good friends
Kayla Ewell we did the pilot for Vampire
Diaries and none of us really knew each
other her and I had auditioned in the
room okay and she played Vicki Donovan
on the show and we were both sitting
next to each other like you know in 20
years we're in first class going to
shoot a pilot in Vancouver and who walks
onto the plane Diane Keaton what color
turtleneck was she wear I think there's
blacker than blacker right it wouldn't
have been a color was she a pet that's
all I imagine that night II wasn't
wearing a hat okay she she had her she
did she did head of a turtleneck uh-huh
oh and she sat right behind us
oh my god so she can look over the
shoulders and everything that you guys
are doing and we assume you know she's
listening to every word we're talking so
any time we'd like mention her we'd be
like so I had this whole thing in my
mind I was like okay I have to say
something she's like you got to say
something I have to say something and my
whole plan was to say thank you for
everything you've done you're an
inspiration to all women in this
business and so we stood up there in the
flight landed when it landed we were
getting off the plane and I just freeze
and she was like hi oh you girls are so
cute are you guys here for a pilot and
like Kayla's cool and like Kat Graham
was in the seat in front of us and they
were both like yeah we're here for the
Vampire Diaries and she's like oh cool a
vampire show like could not have been
nicer and they're all talking to her I'm
just standing with my mouth open like
drool coming down my mouth and then
finally she's like okay and everyone
starts exiting the plane and I like step
in front of her and I was like I just
want to say you are awesome and
literally I was like and I turn around
and Kayla and Kat are looking at me like
I just like what the hell are you doing
just like I'm shaking like holding my
carry-on just walking out being like
that was okay right that was okay
incredible your monologue moment yeah
yeah Mike so from now on any time like
kale and I really just need a boost for
each other we just go like you're
awesome like Diane Keaton I think it's a
really great mantra yeah and I think it
still holds up to this day still holds
up yes that was our that was a good
celebrity food mouse so great well we
have a ton of Twitter questions that
we're gonna get to in one second after
take another quick break we'll be back
with more Candace King you are awesome
right here I'm not sure did he support
for today's show comes from sent bird a
luxury perfume subscription service for
just 4095 semper it lets you choose a 30
day supply of a new scent every month
you can select from over 500 designer
perfume brands like Prada Gucci Kate
Spade and nest or over 450 designer
cologne brands like Hugo Boss gucci tom
ford kancolle etc and they're all 100%
authentic I ordered five different
perfumes they sent it to me you guys
know I'm a smelly human being on a
regular basis so they're really helping
me out and they make it so easy plus if
I don't like the sense that I got I can
switch it up every month 30 days 1495
it's perfect so go to semper comm visit
sanford comm slash grace and pick your
first perfume today use my code grace
jerry ce4 50% off and you can pick your
first perfume for just seven dollars and
fifty cents plus free shipping that
scent bird SC emt bird dot-com slash
grace use my code grace 455 0% off your
first month date a perfume before you
have to commit to it forever
OhLaLa support for today's show comes
from crave made with tender gourmet cuts
of meat and elevated yet simple
ingredients crave jerky is a great
protein that's low in fat gluten free
and contains all natural ingredients and
not to mention the range of flavors is
bold and imaginative from sweet and
tangy to savory and spicy okay they said
me a box full of treasures basically
just so many different varieties of
flavors they have they're fascinating
not something I would necessarily put
together in my head but something in my
mouth that makes complete sense
they're sweet Chipotle beef is amazing I
love Chipotle flavors it's a little bit
sweet but it's still tangy it's still
savory it's still like a great snack on
the go they also have other crazy
interesting flavors like lemon garlic
Turkey garlic chili pepper beef chili
lime beef black cherry barbecue pork
that one's my favorite there I mean it's
all there you gotta collect them all yes
so delicious so try one of craves bold
tender flavors like chili lime beef or
black cherry barbecue pork just go to
crave jerky calm that's crave with a K
and you'll get 20% off when you use the
offer code grace GRA CES that's crave
jerky kr a VE jerky com offer code grace
and get 20% off your taste buds well
thank you that's not their log line but
it should be we're back with the
effortlessly a lovely Candace King
Kenneth before you get into these
Twitter questions I have two questions I
ask every single guest that is on my
podcast
and the first is who alive or dead would
you most want to throw cold spaghetti at
ok I've thought about this a lot on a
very deep level thank you
and I didn't want to get too political
about it and then I thought about a lot
of the reality show celebrities we just
talked about and then I'm like you know
what they're just doing their thing on
reality TV so then I really decided to
friend point one person who really
irritated me in the last week and it's
this older cranky woman that I saw on
Whole Foods who first of all was
blocking the import like the significant
cheese aisle I'm hosting a party but
feta goat cheese single slices people
are trying to get to if they've got
three kids to feed
so she blocked it for a long time and
then she ended up behind me in the
grocery line and I have my two and a
half year old like in the little front
bucket seat and she's guys like she's
pretty adorable she's there's a lot of
people over so she starts being like oh
look at me I'm a baby and then the woman
is like how old is she and I say oh you
know she's and she's like is she three
and I say oh yeah you know she'll be
three in January mmmm
and she goes so she's not I said excuse
me and she goes so she's not three she's
two and I was like well she's like
two-and-a-half she's like yeah but
that's not three and I was like you know
people round differently I don't know
what to say I would have loved in that
moment to throw like stick her face I
don't know that we've ever had such a
dissertation answer to this question and
I could not appreciate it more I feel
like I lived that moment with you with
that crotchety woman blocking the
significant cheese also the phrase
significant cheese is not gonna be added
to my glossary for the rest of my life
I'm very passionate about grocery store
aisles
well that woman's a huge fan of the
podcast so she'll hear what she's done
yeah and hopefully about it okay the
other question I ask every guest is to
tell us your worst pants shooting story
okay close call but you can only use
three words or three like small phrases
or some kind of iteration of those -
college jogging front lawn yes one that
I was aware of or maybe not even birth
so I'm just I just assumed maybe like
assumption birth silence you do it and
no one tells you and no one tells you I
heard
you know who did tell me about that John
Green
best-selling author John Green told me
that his wife [ __ ] the table when they
had their first child and he didn't know
that that was gonna happen and people
should know that that's gonna happen he
told me this on camera in an interview
that I did for his best-selling novel
and it was an eye-opening experience
yeah a little Looking for Alaska no it
was the Fault in Our Stars
yeah yeah it's the fault in their bowel
movements apparently okay let's get into
these Twitter questions so one of the
main ones that we've gotten which I
really want to ask you about is like
what's the next project that you're
working on because I know you have a
podcast that by the time this comes out
we'll be out and everyone's kind of
curious cuz it's been a little like you
know kidnapped and Arab swing-wing yeah
so tell us about this first of all I
have crazy obsession with Kayla Ewell
she was one of my best girlfriends we
really got to know each other filming
The Vampire Diaries and we've remained
really good friends for years and years
and ever since and I've always want to
do something fun with her and so you
know as sometimes you get drunk and are
on your bathroom floor with your best
friends we decided hey we talked a lot
about life in our 30s and how we don't
really have it figured out and we love
listening to podcasts maybe we could
have a podcast where we talked to people
that we think are really awesome and
inspirational and could give them give
us some direction in life and share that
with the world and we're like yeah let's
go pour another drink and do that
conversation so we came up with
directionally challenged because we feel
like we both are it's a great name thank
you yeah it's really great it's pretty
true to Jack and I came up with this not
on a bathroom floor but drinks in a bar
or scenario yep yep
I'd fully understand the creative
process yeah conceptualizing this but
it's really fun I think that we've
gotten to learn a lot about ourselves
individually it's been a really fun
avenue for our friendship to go down
yeah has it been because you work so
much in like the traditional you know
acting space this must feel like a new
outlet where you get to kind of be a
little bit more unfiltered I would guess
yes yeah neither of us are very good at
online social media at all like if
someone's like your gran begs to differ
it was very curated like I'm one of
those annoying curated picture people
like I'm not one of those like hey look
at my pimple and I mom live like I was
like rent to it too for that to be my
brand but like that's equivalent to the
celebrity foot-in-mouth meeting someone
I also I appreciate the the curation of
the aesthetic I think it's like very
cool I'm very interesting so it must be
nice to be able to do something that
feels a little less like a little bit
more just like casual yeah if we're at a
dinner we'll both be like chatty chatty
chatty story story story you know yes
but then put us on you know Instagram
and it's like a little bit it's just an
uncomfortable medium like I don't wanna
speak for Kayla but we've talked about
it it's just never been a comfortable
medium for either of us any of the
social media platforms so this has been
direction elite challenged has really
been a great opportunity where we talk
about real life we talk about you know
failures and successes we talk about
embarrassing stories we talk about our
marriages and kids and your real people
we talk about our real people stuff so
we might not be posting pictures of our
pimples on Instagram but you can hear us
talk about them in a different way like
by the time this comes up this podcast
will be available I'm assuming wherever
podcasts are consumed yeah iTunes
SoundCloud all of that all of those
it'll be on your social media yes
beautifully curated social media up a
little bit and getting comfortable we
might do an Instagram live
yeah once or twice I've never done it
before you were telling me before we
start recording it like some of the
episodes seem nuts so like if you would
give kind of like a little teaser to
people that might not have like checked
it out yet like you just said you talked
to a porn star about being a mother
which is a crazy sentence to say but
that's like a real conversation because
turns out she too is a real person ya
know we when we worry kind of going back
and forth on ideas of who we would want
to talk to her just things that we were
struggling with yeah it was kind of just
the reality that we were both married
women like how do we keep up this vais
appealed not not any responsibility of
our partners but yeah like how do you
feel do you feel
tsylia I don't I've really struggled
with feeling sexy within myself after
having a baby I'm sure and also you're
in an industry that constantly pressures
do to be beautiful yeah I was back in a
bra filming a like sexy time scene about
four months post five months postpartum
you're filming sexy time scenes while
you're pregnant like yeah it's a lot to
mentally handle it was a lot and so
coming moving forward from that we were
like well why don't we talk to someone
who this is their industry and their job
so we spoke with Tanja tape on what we
thought was going to be about like sexy
stuff but we really got to know her and
and she's a new mom and she had a lot of
which you can hear on the podcast she
struggled with fertility her and her
husband and so they she breaks it down
like their whole journey to becoming
parents and also then how that works
into how she feels now as an adult film
star and finding her own sexiness back
and I was like well that makes me feel
better that sometimes you just see all
these celebrities that bounce back and
are just like flawless after having a
baby and I'm like I'm covered in spit-up
and I haven't shaved my legs and I don't
know like how to feel sexy talking about
like oh the baby's crying again so it
was nice to just have it all humanized
from someone that I would have assumed
would it would have been effortless from
them so it was actually a much deeper
emotional talk than we anticipated which
was great and then we have a bunch of
friends that come on our friend Becca
Tilley is our first episode and she was
on I we are all part of bachelor nation
and oh don't get me started that's
another two-hour episode of this the way
down that wormhole oh yeah so we just
talked with her and like her journey a
bit and we were kind of just talking
about like instant gratification knows
you know the show The Bachelor you're
instantly supposed to be in love and
different things like I can see myself
falling in love with ex person yeah it's
crazy it's nice but that's so cool and
so you get to have these kind of like
free-flowing conversations that are more
real I imagine than a lot of this
Hollywood work that you do yeah and it's
nice we kind of pick a topic that we all
can relate to and genuinely it's we
think that people have a better
active on it our friend Jenna Ushkowitz
she came by and she's an actor and she
was an actress on Glee for years and and
so she came because she had a podcast
about failures and the week that she
came she had won a Tony for producing a
Broadway play we were like thanks Jenna
really what a fun really set in the low
high failure bar for us here your
failure is winning a Tony alright so I
need to rethink some things but it's
crazy she's been on Broadway since she
was you know before she was even double
digits so I mean her whole journey
taking us through her career was like
wow yeah you really need you know yeah
it's a journey it's not just a its
lineup Hill yeah travel yeah there's a
lot of twists and turns but that's very
cool so if you guys haven't already
check that out please go check out that
podcast yes it is available like we said
we're all podcasts are found the other
thing people are really interested in is
collective journeys yeah yeah tell us
about this it's a bracelet line yeah but
what's really fun is every month we
release a new bracelet and 15% of the
proceeds go to a specific small charity
that we're partnering with that month
that's awesome and so we started this
May and we're so it's been really a
great journey to be able to meet all
these different local charities but so
we started with the charity called
harvest home and they house pregnant
homeless women and rehabilitate them and
they actually to live in this home for
up to three to six months postpartum to
bet depending on how long until they
kind of find a job and are able to move
on and but it's this huge house in
Venice that has this insane history
means I'm only ever helped women it's
been a women housing helpful home it
since the early 1900s when I guess women
used to take the canal boats over there
and it's on this insane like lot in
Venice where we were all wondering like
how it's so expensive to live in Venice
how does this happen
and they rent it for a dollar a year
from the church like it's just as part
of the community where you could drive
by it a million times and not know
there and I just love that it's this
home that has just been meant to help
women that are struggling or going
through a tough time since the early
1900s Wow
and so getting to know the women there
and and all these women that are also
supporting these pregnant women and
learning about that community and so
that was the first charity we worked
with and we've gotten to know them so
while I'm going to emcee their big event
in October it's awesome so it's really
fun and each time you order a bracelet
it comes in this cute little collectible
book and you get to read all about the
charity inside and it's monthly and its
monthly okay cool so we're still looking
at potentially making it into a
subscription in the future but we're
kind of this was our first testing year
and and just getting to know different
charities around LA has been really
inspirational and making me realize like
god there's so many good people in the
world but that's a great way to give
back I mean that's a really one like
jewelry obviously is very funny I'm
pretty and it's fun to create something
on a monthly basis and also an
opportunity to explore charities that
you probably would never have known
about otherwise our big goal
my big goal was to remind everyone that
you don't always have to just go online
and you can go online and donate money
but if you want to get into helping your
community and some community outreach
you can another organization we worked
with this in August it's called happy
period and oh I saw this on your
Instagram yeah so fun this woman named
Chelsea bunch as she started it and they
collect they do big drives and collect
feminine products you know homeless
women and women that can't afford it or
having to choose between like diapers or
pads and earrings because we've all been
that girl in the bathroom who have said
hey girl like next-door do you have an
extra tampon oh yeah you make a tampon a
toilet paper and it is basically a UTI
in the making yeah sorry for the TMI
we've all been there but do you think
about you know even for a lot of
homeless people it's not like they're
welcomed into public restrooms so beyond
even being able to do that it's it's
just providing resources citing
resources and you can do it in a really
fun easy way I literally just had a
bunch of people over a couple Fridays
ago and just said hey guys I'm gonna
have a lot of booze and pizza bring over
a bunch of pads and
tampons and we're gonna pack period kids
that's a great invite I got invited to
that party I'm RSVP'ing immediately so
fun in it so simple and we went over the
hundred bags we were planning on making
we had like almost 200 period kits by
the end of it and then they distributed
at the end of every month so we're gonna
have more so you'll have to come to the
next one so where do people find
collective journeys ww collective
journeys calm or instagram at collective
journeys you can shop from the Instagram
page that's awesome and that's I mean
it's ongoing so like check-in you know
every 30 days or so and we keep them up
you can continue to buy the other months
oh you can retro actively go back so it
just introduced like a new one if you
want to continue the collection Oh
bracelets are a big thing someone to
know what country or countries would you
most most like to visit that you haven't
been to yet cuz you travel a lot things
like travel a lot Italy I was we were
just in Italy for three weeks I want to
go to Antarctica and I want to go to
Peru
oh yeah you want to go away Antarctica
mm-hmm
do you think that's actually gonna
happen I want to my dad says he'll go
with me my husband does not want to go
my dad really wants to go so that is
very Spanish daddy-daughter trip yeah
it's like fly like way down and I think
you have to go down to Argentina or
something and then take a boat you'll
get on a boat and it's like crazy and it
has to be perfect weather to go on the
boat and it's like a - a little over
two-week journey together and then you
get there and then they just like hang
out penguins you know like is there
living situations and like is there a
place to stay you know Liz Merryweather
had a show coming out I don't know if it
ever no yes you read that one oh my
audition for a scientist that living in
Oregon yeah and it's like this
shenanigans that go down so that's my
understanding
ya know same that's I'm like how did
they all get there why are they all
shirtless all the time just a lot of
sexy scientists yeah basically like a
frat house of scientists that are all
down
are to cut are completely isolated and I
just party and like crazy I did see a
Netflix documentary where it is true
people do live down there
well I'm rooting for you and your dad I
have this excursion I think that would
be great
someone to know would you rather never
use a phone again or lose contact with
your best friends oh that's until you
think this through until what's funny is
I actually talk a lot about on our
podcast that I don't like my cell phone
like if I could use my cell phone I
would be so thrilled but do I get to run
into my friends uses a question like can
I see them can I run into them yeah it's
a little um vague of a question you lose
contact with your best friends I think
that you can run into them but you just
don't have like their contact
information okay yeah I pull a sitcom
life-force phones don't exist and I just
knock on their door at the time oh yeah
you actually show up in person every
time you want to ask them I think that's
great someone to know what's the most
memorable moment of your career so far
most memorable moment I'm sure in my
career I'm sure it's kind of hard to
reflect because a lot has transpired it
has I think honestly the dinners at the
end of the the the whole journey like we
had a lot of we I really Milch the
dinners I got as many sitters as I could
plan that this really special wine night
to honor our producers where we all just
drink an insane amount of like Magnum
bottles of amazing wine and all went
around like appreciating each person and
like cried for like three hours and and
that was probably the moment of just
like reflecting like we did this guy's
like we were we were little kids and we
really didn't know how this [ __ ] if the
show was gonna take off and not only did
we do it but we it was like cementing
the fact that we were all just in each
other's lives cared about each other who
really cared about you toward each other
yeah I think that emotional bond that we
all had and even as a crew you know we
had a picture of all the crew members as
well who had been there since season one
so it was just like okay we did this
together I think that was that like okay
I can accept that this is
that's so sweet that's so incredible and
here's to hoping you find that again so
high I'm like everyone goes into a set
new love each other making out all the
time and the best friends you're gonna
chasing that dragon know you have those
memories one of the main questions we've
gotten from a lot of people is like any
words of wisdom or piece of advice that
has either been given to you or
something that you've kind of learned in
the past few years of experiencing this
like whirlwind journey Oh
for anyone I guess is trying to like
kind of break into acting just like a
creative space some of the looks you
like put themselves out there like what
kind of advice would you give to someone
like once you try and like figure out
the creative journey oh man I think I'm
still trying to figure that out I think
it's an evolving process yeah I don't my
husband and I talk about this a lot that
you know you think you have it figured
out in your 20s and you hit your 30s and
you're like nope this is complete mess
yeah I think just to appreciate those
good moments of just this is fun just
enjoy it it is supposed to be fun and
what I'm continuously trying to teach
myself right now is that you can't
control the best things that are gonna
happen to you like it's just gonna like
you have no that we we actually had
Aisha Tyler on our show which is
incredibly numb Mackenzie and they're
really really like great friends and so
in I you showed we were at a birthday
party for a mutual friend and she told
me she's like you have no idea what's
gonna happen in your life yet like and
she's like that's what I always like you
just have no idea she's like when I look
back at all these things I've done I had
no idea you can't plan for those things
so I'm trying to adopt that more on a
daily basis of like let's just enjoy
these small moments cuz I have no idea I
know what I'm working towards I know
what I'm putting my effort into you know
I think that it you have to it's not
just like an opportunity you have to do
the work yeah you've got to do the work
and put yourself out there yeah but then
you can't control what happens from
there and that's okay that's such great
advice I forgot I was doing a podcast
really just listening and being like
this is great I subscribe to this
Candice thank you this has been such an
incredible fun before you leave we're
gonna give you every guest on the
podcast gets a personal
fortune cookies from us to you I love
that you can open it and read exactly
what it says can I eat the cookie you
can we don't fully recommend normally
good but when you have to steam steam
them open and a different fortune and
they're not as delicious I like that
that's okay your husband's photography
skill and taking candid photos of you on
vacation will only get better with time
mainly because cameras in general are
just getting better but let's make you
feel nice this is great I like it ironic
might be specifically tailored to you
and your husband's relationship with
cameras and so Candace where can people
find you online if they don't know just
the general place they can find me on
Twitter I think I'm at Candace it might
still be my maiden name I tweet every
once in a while and you can find me on
instagram at at Candace King you can
find me I think I'm on Facebook but I
have I haven't taken it back I need to
work on completely unsure lose my phone
I know it's my nightmare well I can't is
King I am on the Instagram okay I do it
in stuff stuff go from there and then
you'll branch out and eventually find
her on other platforms and listen to the
podcast if you have an originally
challenge miss King and Kayla you'll
perfect thank you again Candice it's
been really wonderful we'll see you guys
next time another episode of not too
deep goodbye to deep toe deep deep not
too deep is a production of grace helbig
incorporated a producer and directed by
Jack ferry producer and editor
Melissa demons writing by Diane King
production assistants by Audriana Monty
agudo post-production sound by Chris
Henry and an extra special thanks to
Flula for the theme music
[Music]